c'est comme moi vous êtes amoureux des
tornades vous devez absolument tester la
nouvelle attraction chasseur de tornades
au Futuroscope alors j'ai été invité par
le Futuroscope et j'ai testé cette
attraction c'est juste absolument dingue
déjà parce qu'il y a toute une
scénographie qui vous emmène dans cet
univers des chasseurs de tornades en
fait c'est une espèce d'énormes
plateforme où vous allez avoir plein de
sièges orangés vous allez vous asseoir
dedans vous allez avoir l'armée qui va
descendre avec la sécurité et ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que tout autour de
vous et bien vous avez que des écrans
des écrans qui sont fournis par qui par
Samsung tout ça pour vous apporter une
sensation d'immersion et l'immersion
vous l'avez vous l'avez parce qu'à
plusieurs choses qui vont se passer bien
évidemment déjà la plateforme elle
tourne sur elle-même faut savoir ici que
chaque cabinet fait 384 par 216 pixels
c'est comme des petits écrans de 37
pouces et tout ça c'est sur une espèce
de grosse plateforme rotative alors moi
j'étais très très intéressée très
surpris de voir effectivement les
coulisses comment est-ce qu'ils viennent
faire tout ça alors vous avez un espèce
d'énorme Data Center à l'intérieur qui
va venir gérer toute l'animation qui va
venir gérer tout l'affichage avec bien
évidemment et bien une solution de
secours c'est toutefois il y avait un
problème personnellement j'ai adoré
l'affaire donc je vous invite vous allez
à découvrir bien évidemment au
futuroscop